Let's order these
improper fractions
and mixed numbers from
least to greatest.
And there's two ways to do it.
You could put them
all as mixed numbers,
or you could put them all
as improper fractions.
I will write them all-- let's
try it as mixed numbers first
and see what happens.
And then we could also
try improper fractions.
So if we write them
all as mixed numbers,
this expression right
here, this number.
3 goes into 7 two times,
and the remainder is 1.
So it's 2 and 1/3.
Then we have our
4 and 1/2, which
is already a mixed number.
Then this one over here--
3 goes into 4 one time
with a remainder of 1,
so this is 1 and 1/3.
And then you have
1 and 2/5, which
is already written
as a mixed number.
And then finally, we
have this quantity.
15 goes into 17 one time
with a remainder of 2.
So this is 1 and 2/15.
So we already know the
largest number is, just
looking at the whole number
parts of these mixed numbers.
It's 4 and 1/2, so let
me write it out here.
The second largest
number is the 2 and 1/3.
And now the whole number part
of all of these last three--
they're all the
same, so we now have
to look at the fractional part.
And they all have
different denominators.
So to simplify things, or so
that we can compare apples
to apples, let's all give
these the same denominator.
And the best common
denominator will
be the least common multiple
of 3, 5, and 15, which is 15.
So we can rewrite it.
So this is going to be
1 and something over 15.
To go from 3 to 15, you have to
multiply the denominator by 5.
So let's also multiply
the numerator by 5.
So this is 1 and 5/15.
Let's do this one.
This is 1 and something over 15.
We multiply the
denominator by 3,
so we also have to multiply
the numerator by 3.
So let's put a 6 there.
2 times 3 is 6.
And then finally,
this one already
has 15 as the denominator.
This is 1 and 2/15.
So now this is
easier to compare.
They all have 15
as the denominator
in the fractional part
of the mixed number.
The smallest of
these is 2/15, so I'm
going to write it out front.
That's the smallest.
Then the next smallest
is 1 and 5/15,
which is this quantity
right over here, which
is-- I could write
it as 1 and 1/3.
And then the next smallest,
or I guess the larger one
after that, is the
1 and 6/15, which
is the same thing as 1 and 2/5.
And we're done.
And we can then
rewrite them in the way
that they were
originally written.
So this one right
over here in pink
was originally written as 17/15,
so I'll write it as 17/15.
This 1 and 1/3 was
originally written as 4/3.
So I can write it as 4/3.
The 1 and 2/5 was already
written as 1 and 2/5.
And then the 2 and 1/3
was written as 7/3.
And the 4 and 1/2 was
already 4 and 1/2.
Now, the other way to do it
is to convert all of these
into improper fractions.
If we do it that way,
the 7/3 is still a 7/3.
4 and 1/2-- to turn that into
an improper fraction, 2 times 4
is-- well, one way
to think about it--
4 is the same thing as 8/2.
8/2 plus 1/2 is 9/2.
Or a simple way, 2 times
4 is 8, plus 1 is 9.
9/2.
And then 4/3 is already written
as an improper fraction.
1 and 2/5?
Well, 1 is the
same thing as 5/5.
And 5/5 plus 2/5 is 7/5.
Or you could say 5
times 1 plus 2 is 7.
And then finally,
we have the 17/15.
Now, in order to really
compare apples to apples,
we have to have a
common denominator here.
And the least common multiple
of 3, 2, 3, 5 and 15--
it looks like, if we just
had 3, 5's, and 15's here,
it would be 15.
But that's not
divisible by 2, so we're
going to have to go with 30.
So we're going to have 30 as
the common denominator for all
of these.
So 7/3-- to get the
denominator from 3 to 30,
we multiplied by 10.
So we multiply the
numerator by 10.
So we have 70/30.
Then we have 9/2,
but now we're going
to make the denominator 30.
To go from 2 to 30, we had to
multiply the denominator by 15.
So we're going to have to
multiply the numerator by 15.
So 9 times 15 is 90, plus 45.
So that's 135.
Now we have 4/3.
We're going to rewrite
the denominator as 30.
We're multiplying the
denominator by 10,
so we want to multiply
the numerator by 10.
So it's 40/30.
And then 7/5, we're going to
write with a denominator of 30.
We're multiplying
the denominator by 6,
so we have to multiply
the numerator by 6.
7 times 6 is 42.
And then finally, 17/15.
If the denominator's 30, we're
multiplying the denominator
by 2.
So we also have to multiply
the numerator by 2.
17 times 2 is 34.
And now we can compare
apples to apples.
All the denominators
are the same,
so we can just compare
the numerators.
The smallest numerator here is
34, so 34/30 is the smallest.
Then the next smallest--
it looks like 40/30.
And then the next
smallest is 42/30.
smallest is 70/30.
And then the next smallest or
the largest, now, is 135/30.
And you convert these back
down to what they're originally
represented at.
You get this exact
same ordering.